5 55 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about a
big daytime squeeze play at a busy east
side las vegas intersection starting
monday the nevada department of
transportation
is taking eastern down to one lane in
each direction at washington
from five each weekday morning until
three each weekday afternoon
now indot's tony ilya says the lane
restrictions are needed so crews can
start electrical
conduit trenching as part of a nearly
million and a half dollar safety
upgrades going to include
reconfiguring all four corners widening
sidewalks putting in new overhead
traffic poles now if you'd like to skip
eastern during that work there's bruce
to the west and the hobby to the east
so this lane squeeze going to last until
december 11th with the overall project
that is expected to be completed i
believe it is in march of next year
and now all of this information is on
our website eight newsnow dot com just
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me
traffic eight eight news now dot com